when I saw this I was a bit like
confused actually will be confused as
well yeah everyone's doing their own
thing isn't it and it is a very very
unique
boycott Islam net is raising funds to
establish a mjid and Community Center in
Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you will in be reaping a reward click
the link and donate what you
can brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshallah
some people in life they involved in
Haram they do Haram stuff they sell
drugs they drink alcohol they can be
involved in any kind of industry that is
Haram but we're not justifying what
they're doing but they still have a for
the de they still if somebody was to
insult Islam they would get angry and
you would see this at the time of the
Prophet M peace be upon him there were
people like for example there was a
sahaba who had addiction to alcohol but
he was somebody who fought in the Battle
of bad so much so that one of the
companions once because he would he
would he be drunk in front in front of
the Prophet they whipped him and then
one of them I think it was who cursed
him he said may Allah curse you and the
prophet got angry he said don't say that
indeed he Lo indeed he loves Allah and
his messenger sometimes we look at an
evil doer and we think that there is no
IM or they don't hate they don't like
Islam no like the prophet admitted when
I look at you I don't think you don't
have any Islam even though you're
evildoer thank youan you are even spoke
come on so it just shows us that some
people have that g to the de yeah now
this article came out in yeah which is
that basically Moroccan drug dealers who
are basically sorry that escalated fast
so basically who Moroccan drug dealers
so basically they sell weed bro all the
drug dealers sell weed but these
Moroccans specifically if I'm not
mistaken they sell to Israel Zionist
yeah okay so they have decided to
boycott them by not selling the
drugs that's a very unique bik it is I'm
not going to lie it is when I saw this I
was a bit like confused like Shan will
be confused as well yeah yeah obviously
what they're doing is Haram and but the
thing is they still were like we have to
do our bit and I was and I was like
there's some lessons to be learned from
them number one it is Haram what they're
doing of course yeah selling drags like
the prophet saw the man he said what he
earns is Haram what he wears is Haram
and then he expects his Dua to be
answered so they are harming themselves
and we ask Allah subh to rectify their
Fe and for them to repent but do you not
see bro like these people who are
selling drugs are going to level of we
have to do something and they're like
we're going to stop selling drugs to
Zionist like the best thing for them to
do obviously is just to just not to not
to sell it no we know that's that's a
given bro but I mean if they can do that
bro what about your common Muslim family
who was still drinking Coca-Cola and
still buying Israel dates by the way I'm
going to go to Ed road with my wife
inshah and go to these shops and go and
see who's selling what and give them
leaflets to boycott yeah it just show if
you're on edge road bro bro listen
careful if drug dealers are doing this
yeah bro what about Muslim families they
are still drinking Coca-Cola bro they
are still like oh no it's too much you
know can you imagine that your brothers
and sisters been slaughtered and you are
too busy too concerned about your taste
parts like to me that's what I take out
when I looked at I was thinking like
what can I take from that I was like Rob
even drug deal isn't moving like that
even they're doing like that stuff like
that you get saying see doesn't that
teach you a lesson like as Muslims that
we should do more you know even non
Muslims bro even non Muslims are Muslims
are drinking Coca-Cola and these people
are selling
Coke stop the weed but do the Taj weed o
okay you see that's why I'm in the video
basically also shows us like also said
certain people who have worst p in when
they come to Islam they they outdo
certain people do you get it so for me
to see a drug dealer
sorry sorry for me to see a drug dealer
who is boycotting this evil yeah even
though he's involved in evil himself to
me it shows that there is hope there do
you get what I'm trying to say there is
hope there because they are conscious of
certain it's a beginning in it it's a
beginning bro and bro they're doing
they're doing something at least the the
Muslim Muslim rulers are not doing yeah
weed yeah whatever is for that matter
the Muslim rulers if you think about
Muslim rulers are looking at the
spilling of their blood of the brother
sisters these okay what they're doing is
har but you can see Subhan Allah and
we're not justifying it's Haram but at
least they have a heart they're like we
have to do something something in their
hand they're thinking okay what's the
best what in their means in it exactly
so they're thinking the best we can do
is what just not sell it to them and I'm
just like intention there I mean not
that's what I want to say really
anything else you like to finish on no
alhamdulillah it just shows in it that
we we don't just give up again it's that
person that committed 99 murders there
were 99 murders but again you know
people sometimes Islam is to do with
hope and faar yeah it's in the balance
of both have hope but also have fear as
well so when you've got certain people
that feel that their sins are so much
that they shouldn't even turn to Allah
that's wrong because Allah says in a
Hadith to the nearest meaning because
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
rather tells us in a Hadith to the
nearest meaning that even if our sins
Allah says addressing us that even if
our sins were to pile up to the heavens
as long as we ask for forgiveness Allah
will forgive us so there has to be a
beginning there's a there's a first step
to everything you can't just you know
somebody starting you as somebody that's
beginning their Journey you can't
compare your first chapter to somebody's
Chapter 30 you know what I mean like you
make sure that you're a better version
than that you were yesterday so I I
guess that's what it is and it's nice to
see these guys taking the step and
inshallah you got Ramadan coming up
inshallah they will take further steps
and they will relinquish this as well
but alhamdulillah it just goes to show
how United the Muslims are and how the
Palestine issue has United us that
whether you you got the drug dealers
whether you've got the even unit us with
the drug dealers but except except the
super cies can you imagine even the drug
dealers at United but anytime sisters
you have well killed 99 people you have
9 problems just know Allah is one and
he's the one who can forgive your s in
do not ever dispert Ramadan is around
the corner be very careful to the dates
that are being put into the market I'm
going to do a very for video where I'll
be hitting main supermarkets and seeing
how they lab big man need that man got
man's got intellectual baseball bat I'm
going to be visiting in I'm going to
have leaflets that you can download
yourself um go to these stores and do
not buy it yeah they come and the
disguise of certain like oh picked by
Palestinian Farmers yeah they are
working for these Zionist companies yeah
so very very I'm in talks give the ispn
number what to avoid and all that I'm
going to give them a number they're
never going to forget bro okay till next
time brother sisters take
[Music]
care
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala in
the country of Norway click on the link
and donate now for the sake of Allah
subhana wa taala